Toyota knows how to make cars.
It does it so well it became the first company
to produce more than 10 million a year.
Its success is rooted in a special system
and began what is now known as ‘Lean Manufacturing’,
an ethos emulated by companies around the
world to make products faster, cheaper
and better.
Following the Second World War, Japan was
left in a precarious economic position.
"Steel and other metals are scarce"
Already disadvantaged by lacking natural resources,
materials were hard to come by and companies
had to be creative to compete.
Toyota’s founder Sakichi Toyoda had started
a loom business, but it was his son Kiichiro
who founded the motor company in 1937.
They were used to working within narrow margins
- as the shortage of materials increased during
the war, the number of headlamps on its Model
K truck was reduced to one
and it only had brakes on one of the axles.
The turning point for Toyota's Production
System would come in the early fifties, when Kiichiro's
cousin Eiji would travel to the U.S. with
a veteran loom machinist, Taiichi Ohno.
They visited Ford's River Rouge plant in Michigan
and were impressed by the scale of the operation,
but knew that in cash-strapped Japan companies
didn’t have the resources for such a system;
Having months’ worth of stock sitting in
a warehouse would tie up precious capital
they didn’t have.
Instead, what truly impressed Ohno was a visit
to a supermarket, a Piggly Wiggly, according
to legend... Japan didn’t really have self-service
stores at this point - and he was struck by
the way customers could choose exactly what
they wanted, when they wanted.
He decided to model his production line on
a similar idea; With a "supermarket formula,"
only enough parts were produced in the first
phase to replace what was used in the second,
and so on.
This is where the ‘Just In Time’ system
really took shape.
Toyota was able to eliminate much of the waste in Ford's system,
making
smaller numbers of parts to be used when it
needed them, allowing the company to operate
on a tighter budget.
As part of this Ohno developed ‘Kanban’
- a sign-based scheduling method which shows
goods in, goods in production, and goods out.
It’s now seen as a precursor to bar codes.
Ohno and Toyoda also noticed that American
car companies were still employing many of
Henry Ford’s early production techniques
-
They kept operations at full tilt in order
to maximize efficiencies of scale, and then
repaired defective cars after they rolled
off the line.
Ohno believed this caused more problems and
didn’t encourage workers, or machines, to
stop making the mistake.
So he placed a cord above every station which
any worker could pull to stop the entire assembly
if they spotted a problem. The whole team
would work on it, to prevent it from happening
again.
As teams identified more problems, the number
of errors began to drop dramatically.
Combined with a culture of continuous, incremental
improvement -- called `kaizen' -- the Toyota
Production System built a brand known for
making reliable and affordable cars.
But Toyota was also getting good at producing
cars quickly.
In 1962, the company had produced one million
vehicles.
By 1972, they had produced ten million.
It was around that time the efficiencies of
their factories enabled Toyota to produce
a car every 1.6 man hours - much lower than
their competitors in the U.S., Sweden and
Germany
And as the oil crises of the decade sent gas
prices higher, cheap-to-run Japanese cars
became much more appealing to Americans, whose
powerful, but gas-guzzling vehicles suddenly
became very expensive to run.
Today, Toyota has made over 250 million vehicles…
Others have looked to them to learn the lessons
of ‘Lean’- combining craft with mass production,
avoiding waste, while striving for constant
improvement.
Boeing is perhaps the most famous, restructuring
a plant to better suit TPS.
Intel is another long-time lean ambassador,
and is exploring the principles in the context
of AI and IoT.
A Canadian Hospital even used Toyota’s system
to decrease wait times in its ER.
The Toyota Production System changed not just
how cars are made globally but how we approach
making things full stop.
It also showed there is always a better way
to make a product.